votaram todos é e os comportamentos
deveria ter ali uma apresentação costumo
utilizar sendo que acho que que eu
estava aqui é eu estar alguns com sete
no entanto se uma chamada de israel como
disse que é para despachar que estava
entalado anthony a foice foi a
apresentação que também é computador
estava a lei com dificuldades em iniciar
a e portanto também estava com os
problemas tecnológicos é que chova a
transformação digital e o futuro da
agricultura eo futuro de engenharia
agronômica e que estava de vos falar
sobre um assunto que é que está na ordem
de execução as vagas bife de vaca e
universidade de coimbra o que sempre com
a agricultura de precisão e com aquilo
que vos venho aqui dizer hoje é todos
celebrando assim é preciso explicar em
contar a história dos inúmeros artigos
que têm surgido nos últimos dias houve
uma decisão um retorno do retorno do
estado lembra de iluminar os livros de
faca nas cantinas cá pra nós primeira
opção caso é mais cara a cara na vaca do
que outras mas a justificação era que
ambientalmente é uma carne - sustentável
curte das vacas fazem uma coisa que
emitem metano para a atmosfera o gás é
um poderoso
esta decisão é baseada num populismo é
baseada num precioso ao ambientalismo
porque nós analisamos vai não só não só
vai ter um dos elementos do sistema
analisamos o sistema dela está inserido
que é pastagem e vaca é realizada e
sistema vacas em extensiva não só não
emitem como balanço é positivo
conseguem seqüestrar carbono sol
o importante seria caso para dizer isso
aí foi uma informação veiculada de que
só queremos salvar o ambiente
vamos comer carne de vaca regime
extensivo
isto é um bom exemplo do que de comum de
conhecimento da origem é mais decisões
como é que funciona com a agricultura de
precisão a agricultura de precisão é é a
melhor transformação digital resulta do
impacto que as tecnologias de informação
e comunicação time nas nossas vidas e
tem nas nossas vidas
toda a gente não é qualquer coisa que
vai acontecer um dia pouco já está a
acontecer todos nós que usamos uma coisa
deste ano já estamos a beneficiar do que
a transformação digital dentro de um
telemóvel nós temos para o segmento o
documento está em todos os jornais todas
a toda a música e os filmes da netflix
excelências que eu estou aqui há há há
20 anos quando estava a fazer a minha
tese de mestrado luiza
eu trabalho lá em cima e para mandar um
ímã eu tinha que na altura quatro
informática entrar no sistema wax
servidor e consultar enviar hoje em dia
faço aqui em 1994 que é digital setor
agrícola é todo este manancial de novas
tecnologias que vão impactar o
agricultor que quer ser agricultor que é
todos os dias todas as campanhas
decisões
dicas decisões operacionais decisões
táticas e que o que a agricultura de
precisão faz é maneiro agricultora novas
fontes de idade para que essa tomada de
decisão seja melhor seja mais rigorosa
tenha menos erros - cristo isto no tempo
e no espaço
portanto é é a uma janela é dar
oportunidade muito grande para que o
setor faça aquilo que nós agora chamamos
da intensificação sustentável
serão pelo menos da economia que o setor
agrícola está neste momento tem enormes
desafios pela frente um chinelo e
assassinar a digitalização a atuação da
digitalização em si mesmo - afirma sá
outro é volatilidade dos preços ativa
ambiental
e já agora a 11 poucos fala todos
percebemos que existe mas pouco poucas
vezes o hino - eu acho que é de um dos
que nós mas nós temos que preocupar que
é o tal fundamentalismo ambiental do
exemplo das vacas é um exemplo é a outra
seleção que a sociedade tem sobre o
nosso setor e sobre o que a agricultura
está com muitas vezes desfasada da
realidade e desafios e na tecnologia vai
ser uma um grande aliada dos desafios da
agricultura para tornar mais competitiva
e mais sustentável produzir mais com
menos fazer é com que a tomada de
decisão consiga se manter elemento por
exemplo fazer a cultura produzir mais e
gastar e gastar - - - - é feita a
falante o futuro o futuro da agricultura
precisam ou em o futuro da agricultura
vai ser um futuro tecnológico não vai
ser só tecnológico vai ser um futuro
melhoramento genético da história disse
vai ser 1
cumpriu em que nós vamos necessitar nós
sozinhos agrônomo
não vamos conseguir resolver todos os
problemas importantes
eu antes de entrar fez questão de saber
quem era óbvia ser que nós temos hoje
aqui e percebi que temos muitos alunos e
não alunos que não são é que agora nós
temos outros populares da arquitetura e
em cana em até 36 muito importante é nós
o setor agrícola tem demasiados desafios
pela frente e vai precisar muito da
vossa ajuda tecnologias é que hoje em
dia nós temos à nossa disposição
nós já temos é isso não é teoria é
prática eu posso isso é uma atitude mais
uma exploração estados agricultores que
hoje em dia usam imagens de satélite
pericultores que hoje em dia tem som das
águas no sol tem sondas no treino tem
tronos tem equipamentos equipa equipadas
como um monitor de produtividade e com o
sensor gps é todo esse manancial dady
que nós agora vamos ter que ganhar e
vamos ter que transformar em decisões e
portanto é a a lei eu vou deixar essa
parte profunda que o que eu pensei ser é
a qual é principais implicações
principais para os engenheiros agrônomos
[Música]
intel eletrônicos do equipamento temos
sensores e biossensores continuidade
elétrica tem um sensor e quem tem a real
faz escândalo das parcelas temos o vovô
é trabalhar a autonomia dos campos que
tudo isto é isso gostoso para quem não o
é
tudo isto é real e não existem
agricultores a usar em portugal ainda
não é maioria
ou seja muitas vezes me perguntam ok
então essa companheira toda
como é que nós vamos apoiar o serviço
para o agricultor de governo que tem 500
hectares milho como é que faz aplicarem
sobre cultura do de entre douro e minho
que tem dez parcelas com 700 metros de
milho para silagem e vacas
novamente estamos a tentar a encontrar
as funções agora vamos ter é é
aproximadamente a uma esteira uma uma
nova pac e portanto estamos a tentar
encontrar as melhores maneiras em termos
climáticos em termos de disseminação em
termos de atuação né 10 da utilização no
terreno é é uma área que está em grande
expansão neste momento vocês terem uma
idéia é tudo isto começa no final dos
anos 80 do século passado nos estados
unidos com vulgarização do gps na altura
um gps é é um instrumento nos hoje em
dia qualquer telemóvel tem uma antena
gps tenha possibilitado da
geolocalização de adicionar valor
acrescentado aos dados que são colhidos
no treino importante é a evolução tem
sido tremenda eu nem meu doutoramento em
portugal em 2000 comecei a disseminar o
conhecimento na altura eu lembro me que
em 2003 em 2003 fizemos um evento de
disseminação do que a editora precisão
no estande é não estamos máquinas
agrícolas em souselo e enquanto eu
apresentava não era não era assim sempre
nus em powerpoint na era uma coisa mais
tradicional é eu tinha suas na audiência
e até lá atrás como convém a protestarem
dizem que eu era 8 e isso era uma coisa
que era pós estados unidos e que nunca
iria ser aplicada em portugal em 2003
passaram uns aninhos e hoje em dia sou
eu e vários colegas do ferimento de
outras duas instituições é que estamos a
trabalhar nisso que estamos a promover
isso e não não chegam para as encomendas
em temos solicitações eventos da
explicação de informações é que estamos
no bom caminho agora eu sinto e é a
última parte da minha apresentação ainda
vai então aqui duas colegas professoras
do isa
eu sinto que nós não estamos a fazer o
suficiente preparar os nossos bancos é e
nós tivemos só desta casa fez um artigo
mas basicamente dizer que nós temos
desafios enormes no futuro e temos que
começar já vimos ter começado em temos
temos que separadamente tratar desse
assunto para que os nossos alunos não só
na nossa casa mesmo as outras também
saiam com essa formação e então eu é que
tenho aqui quatro coisas que parecem
essenciais para que para formar um um
dinheiro grande preparado para o desafio
de amanhã transformação digital cinema
agricultura 4.0 é curiosamente trata se
chama isso
a utilização da agricultura a que
diferenças carinho é é são os últimos
160 digitalização a dedetização que é
passar do analógico para o digital
fazendo mais equipamento mesmo o mesmo
segmento de cima da decisão
eu gosto mais da transformação digital
porque vamos aproveitar a digitalização
para começar a decidir forma de frente
um exemplo muito prático isso é a
utilização é a utilização da nossa temos
é um clássico do design da unidade
uniforme e da média da parcela mas hoje
em dia e já temos agricultores a fazer
isso
a campanha passada foi decisiva nisso é
a doação foi foi bastante grande e milho
quer em horticultura de passar a fazer é
que a distribuição chamada distribuição
vt o tecnologia taxa variável é quem
quer da zona da parcela
nós aplicamos é uma taxa de frente de
uma taxa de frente de nutria então é 1o
a 24 e chama-se integração ambiental é
então eu eu vou aproveitar com sônia
você tem que ficar aqui minha avózinha
exatamente pronto é importante e eu
penso que é quatro italianos é ignorante
que o primeiro tenha vera e suiça e
assim a economia regional é forte que é
o vencimento de base das disciplinas ou
seja a agricultura está na interface
várias áreas do conhecimento
eu costumo dizer aos alunos os meus
alunos hoje que quando o filho não está
aí desde o turismo marketing ons até a
cambota eo paquistão num touro minhas
colegas igualmente e portanto precisamos
na altura
o que é certo é que nos dá uma barragem
é de viabilidade que ele enfrente que
puna verdadeiramente agricultura desde
sua cirurgia que na sexta cirurgia até
as máquinas até a economia até a
contabilidade até bill dizia química
física e matemática vivo nesta nesta na
charneira tudo isto de facto os
agricultores os setores agrícolas são
jornalistas por natureza um agricultor
que seja especialista em máquinas por
exemplo vai ser uma história grega não
se pode ser o pior patamar eu tenho que
olhar para o todo
o importante é nós precisamos na
formação e isso repito é o isaías e
outras casa somos fortes agronomia
porque sabe muito sol sabe muito
precisamos saber muito fina flor uma
cozinha saber muito de máquinas 177 isso
e isso é fundamental
é hora em cima disso é é exemplo por
exemplo a melhor universidade do mundo
da agricultura está na europa há ninguém
que porque é ao inter em concentrada
tudo basicamente numa grande
universidade
ao invés do que nós temos em portugal é
que temos é é uma disposição enorme
instituições é fizeram uma coisa que
adotaram que seria a minha a minha
segunda é o segundo fator que eu acho
que ela é limitante que a falta de
integração do conhecimento uma coisa que
se chama na o sistema que nós temos
problemas temos problemas complexos nós
temos que usar ferramentas complexas pra
entender é e para resolver e análise de
sistemas
é algo que vem originalmente do século
19 e mais recentemente foi ressuscitado
nos anos 60
né na indústria e ele tem uma aplicação
que certamente nérica coqueiral
conhecimento é e portanto nós é é parece
que ninguém ao topo publicidade mas
luiza temos uma disciplina porque achou
que não mas foi no dia 16 mas é o 69
juízes é nos laboratórios de
investigação muitas vezes sofremos essa
crítica é que há muito conhecimento mas
depois não há pontes não há um estudo da
interligação entre as várias áreas
também está a mudar os próprios grupos
profissionais é já promove um pouco essa
essa ligação pois é finalmente tem 15
anos é duas vezes existe uma área do
conhecimento que é engenharia da decisão
isso nós temos um sistema de moeda
max vê bom tom que se tem aqui se faz
aqui o num contexto complexidade
inúmeras fontes de conhecimento da
verdade é existem ferramentas de que a
inteligência artificial é uma das
últimas mas há muitas ferramentas antes
de programação linear até outras é
existe uma área do conhecimento de
engenharia da decisão ou seja faça a
incerteza faça as probabilidades como é
que eu tomar as melhores decisões com
uma turma treinada função objetivo
geralmente geralmente nas explorações
agrícolas é a maximização das margens
brutas do agricultor minimiza impactos
ambientais e tudo pra finalizar
outra variável e estou 100% de porco o
nosso professor escreveu tal artigo o
professor almeida montanhas formou
recentemente
isso é o que é fundamental que o
conhecimento do treino
não vale a pena se vivamente está mais
do que está não vale a pena nos nossa
nossa investigação está nos ainda
tentaram inventar coisas muito complexa
quando depois o contexto delas vão ser
aplicadas
é um contexto de baixa intensidade
o que é o agricultor é um contraste é é
o que eu quis dizer nos equipamentos que
fui bater na província seja um
equipamento tenha mais que três botões
já não vai funcionar
é importante isso como é que resolve
integrando as equipas não só os
agrícolas não só investigadores mas
também trazer os outros atores e neste
momento temos variadíssimos das
associações de agricultores desde os
próprios agricultores é a all estava o
ministério tem uma série que todos eles
têm que no total ecossistema de inovação
tem que participar para que depois as
funções sejam mais reais e tenham um
verdadeiro impacto e não fiquem espera
uma biblioteca próxima não sabem não
fiquem armazenadas em manuais e em pipas
muito político mas que não sai fica
agora apenas por atletas de bom tamanho
[Aplausos]